نحن نتواجد في المنزل الذي حاصرته القوات
الاسرائيليه عند الثانيه ظهرا بعد دخول
قوات خاصه الى المنطقه تبعتها قوات كبيره
من الجيش الاسرائيلي بمرافقه الطيران الذي
حلق فوق المدينه
ومخيمها دخلت القوات الخاصه والجيش
الاسرائيلي حصلت هذا المنزل وامطرته بحسب
شهود العيان بسته عشر صاروخا بحسب خبرتهم
يقولون بانها صواريخ
انيرجا تهدمت كل جدران المنزل
وسقط في هذا المنزل اربعه من الفلسطينيين
وخارجه
اثنان اخران لتكون الحصيله ارتقاء سته
فلسطينيين وعصابه 17 اخرين اصابه اثنين
منهم
حرجه الجيش الاسرائيلي والقوات
الاسرائيليه تقول بانها استهدفت في هذه
العمليه
الخليه التي تقف وراء عمليه اطلاق النار
في حواره الاسبوع الماضي والتي ادت الى
مقتل مستوطنين اثنين بحسب شهود العيان
ليان فانما جرى اليوم هنا في مخيم الجنين
هو الاعنف منذ العام 2000 منذ اجتياح مخيم
جنين في الانتفاضه الثانيه كم الرصاص
المتواجد
المنثور على الارض وكم الدمار الذي لحق
بهذا المنزل يدلل على حجم العمليه
العسكريه الذي التي شهدها مخيم جنين هذا
اليوم